[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen israelis welt
wir sind gerade noch im wunderschönen
österreich ich habe hier schon so viel
erlebt jetzt sind wir gerade im süden
österreichs wir werden gleich nach
immendorf waren und heute eine
getreidemühle besichtigen und hier
genießen wir noch ganz kurz die aussicht
und dann geht's schon direkt los
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich in österreich erfahren
wie für das kernöl geworden wird was die
unterschiede zwischen cremigem und
flüssigem honig sind dass man eine
knoblauchkröte auch essen kann und ich
habe anna und ihre familie auf dem hof
besucht
[Musik]
hier sind wir beim kyoto mit ihr werden
getreide produkte aller art hergestellt
nicht nur dinkel und buchweizen zb
sondern auch wirklich ganz ganz
besondere getreidesorten und der biohof
hier den gibt's schon seit über 60
jahren auch seit über 25 jahren wird
hier wirklich alles in bio qualität
hergestellt und es ist ein richtiges
generationen und familienunternehmen
hier arbeiten nämlich e-mail johannes
und david den biohof habe ich jetzt
entdeckt war natürlich ausgewählte
produkte beim interspar gelistet sind
und die chance wahren
[Musik]
hier sehen wir eine richtig schöne
auswahl hier zum beispiel jetzt
dinkelmehl es gibt aber auch am rand
oder auch wald steht also auch viele
getreidesorten die ich muss ich ehrlich
sagen gar nicht kannte und wirklich auch
getreidesorten die nicht überall
angebaut werden was hier so auf ganz
besonders ist das müsli das steht hier
vorne da etwas ist das besondere anderem
müsli also das besondere bei uns an
möglich sein
wir haben den anspruch unser eigenes
getreide zu verwenden also wir bauen ja
selber dinkel roggen buch weizen hafer
und gerste auch keinen raffinierten
zucker zu verwenden und das trotzdem süß
zu gestalten entweder mit einer ananas
oder mit etwas heimischem einem apfel
kirsche finde ich besonders wichtig weil
bei müsli ist so schwierig und müsli zu
finden komplett ohne zuckerzusatz vorrat
höher auf die politik laut openbroadcast
das morath der eure eigene backstube
wir haben jetzt seit gut anderthalb
jahre eigene backstube am betrieb und
wir haben dann konstantin wecker
erwischt der für uns dort des brotbox
wir machen auch kleine wecker langsamer
also brötchen wie er sagt aber natürlich
ganz bodenständiges schwarzbrot mit
sauerteig ich sehe hier auch ihr habt
auch sammlungen kerner und auch
leinsamen zum beispiel was ganz
besonderes
ja es wird nichts der ruft angebaut wir
bei uns server und das ist dann die
fertige frucht wie wir sie kannten im
august und verkaufen das sowie 1200
gramm packung rascheln und momentan sind
die leinsamen felder richtig hübsch noch
vor kurzem
jetzt stehe ich hier in dem
wunderschönen leinwand fällt vom biohof
thomik sieht wirklich wundervoll aus die
blüten blühen auch gerade richtig die
leinsamen sind aber erst im august reif
und können dann erst geerntet werden und
dieser wunderschöne anblick ist es doch
wert leinsamen zu pflanzen
[Musik]
so wie bei uns zu haus wenn wir rocken
malen auf mit den steinen die schule
größer
[Musik]
lastet
ich habe mir heiß und damit die haben
schon dieses päckchen für euch gerichtet
richtig lieb von aus aber dafür gibt es
eine frage zu beantworten
ich möchte gerne von euch wissen seit
wie vielen jahren wirtschaften wir hier
am biohof damit schon biologisch also
richtige antwort und in die kommentare
schreiben und wir fahren jetzt noch ein
bisschen gleich raus aufs feld in der
warte der papa schon da wollte ich danke
dir danke
[Musik]
speziell im johannes hier direkt auf dem
soja feld soja war ja schon ne zeitlang
in verruf und ich muss auch ehrlich sagt
gar nicht das ist bei uns hier wachsen
kann also hier bei euch in österreich
aber es hat ja auch sehr gute
eigenschaften den hohen eiweißgehalt
wird es ist das ist eigentlich zu
unrecht in verruf das ist sehr schade
die so heißt eine pflanze die hat dann
eiweißgehalt und die form des alls der
ms baustelle die proteine dieser enthält
sind ihnen so tollen zusammensetzung das
englisch für die menschliche ernährung
ganz optimal werden die sojabohne gehört
zu den hülsenfrüchten und ist eine
richtig hochwertige proteinquelle für
uns menschen
sie enthält ungesättigte fettsäuren und
kaum cholesterin den ursprung hat die
sojabohne in china sie entwickelte sich
zum wirtschaftlich bedeutendsten gemüse
der welt ende des achtzehnten
jahrhunderts gelangte die bohnen nach
europa und amerika und heute sind die
hauptanbaugebiete china indien
indonesien afrika die philippinen süd
und mittelamerika und russland die
sojabohne hat einen schlechten ruf da
viele regenwälder dafür abgeholzt wurden
und auf genmanipulierte bohnen im umlauf
sind
das ist weder für uns menschen noch für
die tiere fordern haben
mal schauen was johannes dazu sagt aber
es ist richtig in den letzten jahren so
ja kommt hauptsächlich aus übersee
südamerika hauptsächlich amerika kanada
und da haben sie damit der
gentechnischen veränderung kommt mir das
so ja umfang und die haben das nur
deswegen gentechnisch verändert der
mitte des prüfungs hatte spritzmittel
vertrocknet dass sie besser wäre dann
mehr träger nur damit die zweite spritze
wieder den wahnsinn muss man sich
vorstellen das heißt wenn man die
spritzmittel komplett weg lässt braucht
man die genmanipulation gar nicht
die brauchen wir generell nicht weil
dies so ist das so natürliche pflanze
die ist ja eigentlich ein bio nie eine
pionierpflanzen überall rasch wächst und
überall wo bisserl mehr temperatur ist
überall wo mais wächst überall wo auch
raps wächst wächst endlich auch die
sojabohne außer auf den großen teilen
deutschland wenn es schwerfällt wachsen
werden
als nachwirkung des zweiten weltkriegs
dürfte europa 50 jahre lang die
sojabohnen nicht anbauen
amerika hat in europa nämlich so viele
kredite gegeben dass die eu diese nicht
zurückzahlen konnte also beschloss
amerika ihr europäer müssten den
wichtigsten baustein bei den
lebensmitteln bei uns kaufen
die nächsten 50 jahre musste also europa
die sojabohne aus den usa kaufen und
daher wurde die sojabohne in europa
komplett vergessen
ich bin jetzt seit 25 jahren aktiver bio
betrieb verzichtet seit 25 jahren auf
sämtliche chemie auf jeglichen decker
dünger bin auch stolz drauf dass ich
finde jetzt bisher einsparen kann kann
man das irgendwie ausrechnen wie viel
jünger ihr eingespart hat uns ja wenn
ich das also wenn ich ein
konventioneller betrieb geblieben wäre
und körnermais angebaut dass wir den
meisten hier und den dünger den tief
erwähnen hochrechnung auf meine fläche
dann werden es mittlerweile schon 5,5
millionen kilogramm düngemittel die ich
jetzt nicht aus gebracht habe und stolz
bin drauf wir brauchen und das ist oft
ein trugschluss manche denken die bio
bauern brauchen keinen stickstoff das
stimmt nicht die sojapflanze gehört zur
art der leguminosen kreuzbreite oder
schmetterlingsblütler genau richtig
richtig und die die leguminosen sind in
der lage mit bakterien eine symbiose
einzugehen und diese bakterien flüssig
auf der wurzel sehr wohl und die bildern
hier so können deswegen heißen sie auch
knöllchen bakterien und wenn man jetzt
sein glück kommen und reinschauen wird
es schön rot und saftig sein und dieser
saft drinnen der rote saft das ist
reiner stickstoff und diese pflanzen
diese kombination dieser symbiose die
natur und es gibt ja das ist ein
geschenk des himmels und bis in mein
gesamten stickstoff team diese pflanze
und die folge pflanze in unserem fall
wird er meistens dollar dinkel als brot
getreide angebaut weil getreide ist
überhaupt nicht in der lage mit gleichen
bakterien symbiose einzugehen die nutzte
an diesen stickstoff in folge heraus um
einen tollen ertrag zu bringen richtig
toll johannes beeindruckt mich sehr und
ich hoffe das so ja nicht nur ein tier
futter bleibt sondern auch bei den
menschen wieder an gut bekommt genau wir
haben es jetzt schon getestet wir haben
schon bei einem müsli von uns mit
eingebaut haben wir und dieses witzige
sogar das wir wir sind ja schon in der
lage auf unserem hof einmal der erste
bio bauer in kärnten dem es gelungen ist
die sojabohnen dann auch zu rüsten
weil das musste weil die haut aber
inhaltsstoffe das würde sonst die rehe
und alle gern wegfressen weil sie so gut
ist jetzt hat sie ein paar so
bitterstoffe drin
die die verdauung von eiweiß blockieren
den müssen wir ausgehen dazu thomas
rüsten und die gerüste terrier größte
soja kuchen in kombination wir machen
statt zucker im müsli getrocknete äpfel
die man da reingeben schmeckt spd-mann
schnitten die deutschen kennt man
schnitten auch oder was ist er genial
ist ja vielen dank dann hoffe ich dass
er so wieder in ruhe wachsen kann schön
hoch bis ende september wieder geerntet
für mich warst ja bei dieser station wir
fahren jetzt weiter und ich hoffe dass
ihr euch noch mal überlegt was man alles
mit dem soja anstellen kann und vor
allem wie wertvoll er auch für den
menschen ist
[Musik]